the blistering heat wave in the
southwest could get even worse today
record high temperatures were set
yesterday in California Nevada and
Arizona Phoenix had 118 degrees today
the temperature in Phoenix could reach
120 Kris Van Cleave is at Sky Harbor
International Airport where the heat is
even grounding planes Chris good morning
good morning the Sun isn't even up and
we're over 90 degrees it's only going to
get hotter as the day goes on when we
hit 118 some small planes those regional
jets where your bag doesn't fit in the
overhead bin they can't safely take off
so American Airlines has canceled or
delayed at least 50 flights so far
because of this extreme heat even desert
dwellers will tell you this it's just
too hot Phoenix is known as the Valley
of the Sun but right now it feels more
like the surface of the Sun prompting an
excessive heat warning for southern
Arizona for the rest of the week
don't try to out beat the heat because
the he got out beat you this heat when
we talk about a hundred and twenty
degrees plus is that life-threatening
heat it is it's life-threatening heat
for all populations all ages Phoenix
Fire captain Rita Bigler you can skip
right past heat exhaustion and go into
heat stroke which is your body's
inability to cool itself
we rode with engine 18 as the heat
soared to 118 Phoenix Fire has already
seen a surge of heat related emergencies
like this one he was having some
cramping some nausea some of the signs
that we look for
related problems et is the peak heat of
the day about 118 degrees outside the
car even hotter the handle about 150
degrees that's almost too hot to touch
when you get inside the car the - 144
degrees the intense heat is contributing
to wildfire conditions in Nevada Utah
and Southern California where a brush
fire quickly grew to hundreds of acres
Monday afternoon
further north it was so hot in West
Sacramento California a major highway
buckled rising off the ground as much as
four inches and in Fresno California
hundreds were forced to evacuate a fast
rising river fueled by rapidly melting
snow we didn't know that was going to
rise but we didn't expect this at all
Phoenix has only hit 123 times in
recorded history the hottest 122 that
was back in the 90s some good news is a
bit of a cooling trend on the way by
Friday it'll be a balmy 113 Charlie
thanks Chris